لا تزال صناعه المنظومات المسيره تشهد
عمليات تطوير بهدف زياده قدرتها وفعاليتها
سواء في جانب صناعه المسيرات او المنظومات
المضاده لها شركه اندرال الامريكيه اشتهرت
مؤخرا كونها واحده من الشركات المنتجه
لمسيرات بريه وجويه وكذلك بحريه وايضا
منظومات مضاده لطائرات المسيره للوقوف
اكثر على احدث منتجات الشركه ودورها في
هذا المجال معنا في الاستوديو رئيس مكتب
الشركه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط السيده جون
ماكدونالدز اولا مستر جون اهلا بك معنا
وشكرا على وجودك معنا في اهل الاستوديو
مستر جون الكثير من المسيارات موجوده في
الاسواق اليوم لكن ما الذي يميز المسيرات
التي تقدمها شركه اندرويد
سواء اندرس
بتطوير البرمجيات وليس المعدات فنحن شركه
برمجيات مدعومه بالمعدات لدينا افضل
مهندسين البرمجيات من شركات اوكولوس وسبيس
اكس ومايكروسوفت والافضل في جنوب
كاليفورنيا نحن نستخدم الحوسبه المتقدمه
اي ان المعلومات لا تعود الى كمبيوتر كبير
مما يتسبب في بطء العمليه بل المعددات
فيها رقاقه الكمبيوتر مثل تلك الموجوده في
هاتفك وتقوم باغلب العمل على المعدات مما
يقلل المعلومات العائده الى الشخص المسؤول
في حلقه اتخاذ القرار ولقد قررنا ان الشخص
المسؤول في حلقه اتخاذ القرار هو الاسلوب
الصحيح للقيام بالعمل اي ان الانسان يبقى
له الاثر والقدره وفي نفس الوقت اخرجناه
من الحلقه لاننا اردنا ان تقوم البرمجيات
بالعمل وبلا شكل لا نريد ان يكون هناك شخص
خارج حلقه اتخاذ القرار فالانسان دائما
موجود في هذه الحلقه لقد تعاونا مع افضل
شركات التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ذات الخبره في
العالم فنحن لا نبني محركات المروحيات ولا
نبني شفرات المروحيات نحن ناخذ من افضل
الشركات وبافضل قيمه ثم نجمعها مع
برمجياتنا من اجل المضيق قدما بسرعه كبيره
جدا مثال على ذلك كم هو عمرها هاتفك عام
واحد نعم اذا اخر تحديث تلقائي كان ربما
قبل بضعه اسابيع نفس الشيء ينطبق على
البرمجيات حيث نقوم بتحديثها بشكل دوري
واسرع بكثير من قدره مقتنيات الدفاعيه
السابقه وبالتالي فالدينا اسلوب مختلف
للحصول على برمجيتنا وهو عن طريق الاشتراك
الذي يشبه اشتراكك بخدمات الهاتف السنويه
مما يحافظ على تحديث البرمجيات بشكل مستمر
اذا تحديث المستمر هو اهم يميز مسيراتكم
في شركه اندرال لكن فيما يتعلق بالمنظومات
الاعتراضيه للطائرات المسيره انتم اعتمدتم
في التقنيه التي تقدمونها على مسيره
اعتراضيه ضد المسيره العاديه لماذا هذه
التقنيه بالضبط وما الذي يميز هذه التقنيه
عن غيرها من التقنيات المضاده او
المنظومات الاعتراضيه للمسيرات بشكل عام
ويجلس السؤال
قررنا تطبيق العلوم والفيزياء ليس فقط مع
البرمجيات فعلينا ان نتذكر انه خلال
القيام بعمليه مكافحه المسجلات فلدينا وقت
قصير جدا الاعتراضها لذلك طورنا اسرع
مسيله ممكنه وتذكر ان المسير التي تحلق
باتجاه هنا حجمها يساوي حجم الحمامه ومن
الصعب جدا اكتشافها ولذلك لدينا رادارات
جيده جدا مركبه على ابراج وترسل مسيراتنا
الى ذلك الاتجاه وبعد ذلك تهاجم من الاسفل
الى الاعلى والسبب وراء ذلك هو ان الحوسبه
المتقدمه جدا في الرادار قدرتها كبيره في
استكشاف السماء ورؤيه الهدف بشكل كامل من
دون اي معوقات من الارض لذلك طبقنا
العلومه لتجاوز بعض نقاط ضعف التكنولوجيا
وكذلك لتقليل الاضرار الجانبيه الناجمه عن
الانفجار لان مسافه اعتراض الهدف ستكون
على بعد كيلومتر ونصف منا وسيسقط الخطام
في المنطقه القريبه واخر ما يميز هذه
القدرات هو دقه النجاح في التخلص من الهدف
التي تبلغ
98% حسب تقييم الوكاله الامريكيه خارج
شركاتنا طيب فيما يتعلق بمستقبل صناعه
المنظومات المسيره بشكل عام مستر جون الان
هناك الكثير من الشركات التي تعتمد على
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي اين انتم في
اندريل من الاعتماد على هذه التقنيه
سوداء
الامر
التالينا واخلاقيتنا فتخيل كل الاشياء
التي يمكن للمسيره ان تقوم بها والتي لم
تكن ممكنه في السابق بسبب الكلفه مثل كل
الصور الجميله التي نحصل عليها من
المسجلات والاستكشافات التي توصلنا اليها
الان ولم نتمكن من تحقيقها في الماضي بسبب
عدم قدرتنا على التحليق الى تلك الاماكن
او لانها كانت مكلفه جدا مثال على استخدام
هذه المسيارات هو في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ للوصول الى الاوديه العميقه في
جبال الامارات
والعمل الذي يستغرق الاشخاص اياما للقيام
به يستغرق دقائق او ساعات الانجازه
باستخدام التكنولوجيا ومسيلاتنا الذاتيه
مؤخرا ارسلت احدى مسيراتنا الخاصه بعمليات
الاستطلاع بعيده المدى الى اعصار ايان في
الولايات المتحده لان طائره هانتر المخصصه
للاعاصير تضررت كثيرا واعيدت الى القاعده
لذلك اطلقوا المسيرته وتمكنوا من تحمل
رياح بسرعه
155 ميلا في الاعصار ويتمكنت من القيام
بما لم تتمكن اي طائره من القيام به
والتكنولوجيا مكنه الخبراء من التعرف على
اتجاه الاعصار مما اسهم في انقاذ الارواح
لانهم حذر السكان وطلبوا منهم الابتعاد عن
مسار الاعصار
فيما يتعلق ب- اا يعني وجود شركه اندرال
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط انت رئيس مكتب
الشركه مستر جون هنا في هذه المنطقه اولا
كيف تقيمون شركاتكم وتعاونكم مع دول منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وكذلك ما هي الدول التي
تعتمد على المنظومات التي تقدمونها في هنا
في المنطقه
العيال
المتحده ونحن منفتحون لتقديم التكنولوجيا
الدفاعيه البارزه الى المنطقه حيث يكون
ذلك مناسبا تذكر انه من بين اهم ثلاثه
اولويات الشركائنا وحلفائنا في المنطقه هو
اولويتا هما مكافحه المسجرات الجويه
ومكافحه تهريب البشر والمخدرات التي بدات
تتزايد في كل هذه الدول وعلى سبيل المثال
نحن منشغلون على حدودنا الجنوبيه الشرقيه
مع مئتين 280 برجا فقط شيدنا جدارا
افتراديا في جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده
ومراقبه الحدود والجمارك قبضوا على اربعه
اضعاف الاشخاص الذين قبضوا عليهم في العام
الماضي جزء من ذلك يعود لاعاده استخدام
القوه البشريه والقوه البشريه في الشرق
الاوسط محدوده ولذلك يمكننا الان استخدمه
هذه القوه الب بكفاءه اعلى وترك العمل
للالام مما يترك المجال للبشر لايجاد
الحلول لتلك الاولويتين وبين خفر السواحل
والشرطه وامن الحدود نحن نقوم باشياء
كثيره هنا في الشرق الاوسط ونحن متحمسون
لوجودنا هنا شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
وعلى كل ما تفضلت به من توضيحات مصر جون
ماكدونالد رئيس مكتب شركه اندرول
الامريكيه هنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا